[Music]
[Applause]
i was strolling through the uh the
internet looking at websites and all of
a sudden i saw this article it said that
uh laker players were texting
during a game
and then i saw the byline is by my good
buddy a uh former uh teammate of mine in
college steve bullpit the senior nba
columnist for heavy.com spent a lot of
years covering the celtics for the
boston herald and uh bulpit joins us on
the program steve good to see you again
how did uh how did you come about the
texting on the bench with the lakers
it wasn't on the bench daniel it was uh
half time
if you
read the story i'm not sure if you took
the reading comprehension class at uv
uh yeah no seriously it was it was at
halftime and um
you know basically talking to a bunch of
gm's and people around the league as you
do regularly for the job
and this stuff started to come out and
it just really looks like it was a mess
out there
okay but do we know who was texting uh
is lebron in on this it kind of felt
like in the article you're talking about
the the disrespect that not only you
know the it felt like the
front office had disrespect for frank
vogel that the players liked him but
here they are you know texting during
halftime
well i know at least i know definitely
one of the people who is texting
um but it uh yeah
i can't say who it was but yeah
definitely i know one
and that person said that uh he wasn't
uh according to the quote wasn't the
only mf or texting at the time
cleaned it up for you bud
but you know now do you think stories
are going to come out now because
vogel's gone and maybe there was more to
what was going on behind the scenes
well actually the the story about the
texting uh
was brought to me like a while back
but we were developing trying to develop
it uh but yeah no there was this stuff
was going on for a while and i point out
this was
this incident or you know
the incident that this points to that of
the situation it points to
actually occurred when they were you
know months ago when they were still you
know thought to be a team that hey this
team's going to be good and when it gets
its stuff together
so this wasn't one of these things like
the last couple of weeks
you know as uh as the ships taking on
water this was back when they were
supposed to be good
you also mentioned that kurt rambis
would air out frank vogel in front of
the team
how often was that happening
i'm not sure how often but it was
certainly you know it wasn't uncommon
um as i was told and again this is
something it's like you know
you know the deal in the business if if
someone tells you something it's like
okay do i trust this person but then
you've got to talk to other people as
well
so you know hearing that from multiple
people um and
everything in the in the story was you
know
other people knew it as well so it
wasn't like a a
a quiet thing or something that was
hidden
why do you think there was a disconnect
between russell westbrook and frank
vogel
you know i'm not sure um
but look when you
when you bring guys on to a team
um
they
they can't be everything that they were
perhaps individually
you know let's look back at the
2007-2008 celtics when they bring uh
ray allen and kevin garnett to join paul
pierce every one of them talked about
what they were going to have to
subjugate in their own game to make the
whole thing work um and i'm not sure
you know you you can look at it and i
seriously
the whole way along until it was clear
that they were out of this thing i
thought if this stuff if this team gets
healthy
they could be a problem for someone but
uh
they probably never had enough time
healthy together
but
uh it just it just seemed like guys are
trying to be who they were
uh individually or trying to get the
their most out of themselves
figuring that would help the team best
that way and i don't think they ever
latched on to an idea of what's going to
be good
for you know for the whole here
the ideal coach for the lakers would be
who in your opinion
uh
um
i it's weird because i i think the the
ideal coach has got to be someone that
has some control with the front office
because i think that's where the
problems are stemming um you know you've
got to create a roster that's going to
work
not just like as someone pointed out in
the story you know not just uh
rotisserie baseball here or just read
basketball
so you know um
i hesitate with some of the names that
have been mentioned but um you know i i
think
i don't think any self-respecting coach
would get anywhere near this
until the problems upstairs are cleared
out
or cleared up
yeah but how are they going to be
cleared up or cleared out
well um
i don't know someone's gotta if the
coach you hire has some control there
that would help
or if you bring in someone um
you know that uh a stronger a stronger
gm
that has an idea of team building
you know or the people that are there
all of a sudden change their attack
and you know figure out like what's
gonna what's gonna make us here because
if you if you look at them now daniel
the
the
the contracts that you're weighed down
with
and the draft picks that you don't have
that you can't use to
as as assets to to spend in the market
that's a hard
hard situation to see anyone digging
themselves out of
phil jackson's not walking through that
door is he
you know i have too much respect for
phil's intelligence to think he'd do
that well he did go to the knicks steve
well you know someone throws a whole bag
of money at you
do you think that they would at least do
a drive-by with phil jackson
uh
yeah i i do um
i'm sorry can i divert here for say it's
funny you mentioned the term drive-by
and phil
there is this little dive bar out in
playa del rey
that uh a close friend of mine who
passed away frank hamblin was an
assistant coach for a long time and a
bunch of people would hang out at this
place a really small you know small bar
and uh phil lived nearby
and sometimes phil would drive by the
place on his way home slowly
make sure he got someone's attention the
window and flipped the bird and that was
known in the bar as a phil jackson
drive-by
who's he flipping off
just
as a joke it was basically like you know
the people in the bar so that was like
yeah did phil do a drive by tonight
so you mentioned phil and drive-by yeah
i apologize for veering off
multiplaya del rey
before i let you go explain to me zion
williamson was the best player on the
floor and not playing doing 360s prior
to the game
why is he not playing
i don't know i mean
i guess you know you can do something
for a few minutes but can you do it long
enough on a court to sustain and should
he be doing 360s in front of people with
cameras there because that just leads us
to believe like why are you not playing
well you know
you used to pass the ball in warm-ups
that's true
but not during the game
i know
well why throw it to somebody who wasn't
as good a shooter as i was i mean that's
really the philosophy that i had steve
my stock line was that uh dan had a
three to one assist ratio years to
assist
[Laughter]
but actually i'm gonna i'm gonna
probably piss off your your staff there
you know how good dan tells you he was
he was probably actually better than
that you carried us but yeah
well you know what the only way to stop
me steve was with a handgun and league
rules frowned upon that so
just letting you know
hey we did we didn't we didn't have
metal detectors at the field
no we did not i was a gunner absolutely
positively uh yes paulie yeah dan we
don't get this opportunity that often
steve if you have any other stories that
are passable for national radio or
television
bring them up this is it
uh
there are several um
yeah no they're
how about the one in atlanta dan where
you were uh
giving a hard time to that intern at
that party that night calling that guy
meat and stuff
and he went after you
no
i don't call on some guy meat hey me
that sounds like you
i don't know who i and it was somebody
at cnn
yeah
and i was calling him meat hey meat i
think it's probably like a takeoff of
the of bull durham or something yeah
yeah and we were at this party outside
and this guy decided it's a large man
uh a younger man and he decided uh he
had enough of that
and uh he started to come after you and
we were you know i grabbed the guy and
pulled him against the side of the house
and you know
you can't hurt the talent uh explain
that to him it would be bad for his
career
uh i think i mumbled that to him but the
next day or uh
the celtics had played the hawks that
night the next day we were flying to the
next city
and um
the trainer on this is back in the
celtics were flying commercial tell you
how long ago it was uh and the the
trainer saw my hand it was kind of
gashed and he go he looked at it and uh
i think i would probably still buzz from
the previous night but he said i needed
to get stitches when we got to the next
city
thank you for taking one for the team
there you go daniel
uh great to see you bulpit thank you and
uh good luck buddy
you as well sir i hear you've done
pretty well for yourself yeah you know i
you know i'm starting to make a carving
out a career here you know it's slow how
do you how are you thank you steve steve
bulpitt senior nba columnist for
heavy.com had the story